varados en los aeropuertos de Perú y
Colombia permanecen cientos de viajeros
que volarían por la aerolínea colombiana
de bajo costo vivaaer que de manera
inesperada suspendió operaciones debido
a problemas financieros personas
alteradas en Medellín Cali Barranquilla
y Bogotá esperaban una solución entonces
en la noche cuando quisimos hacer el
checking para ir a Cartagena
cerró prácticamente Viva su su su su
página y no dio ninguna respuesta más
que un comunicado que tiene problemas
internos que yo no sé cuáles son los
problemas sinceramente Pero simplemente
ya no dan cara de mi país y tenía el
tiquete ya de vuelta Así que nada la
verdad que Colombia Es hermoso todo la
pasé re bien las vacaciones pero yo
necesito volver tengo que trabajar soy
docente tengo que dar clases Así que
nada quiero
quiero volver y a mi país la aerolínea
Busca desde abril del año pasado que la
aeronáutica civil organismo encargado
del control de la Aviación apruebe su
integración con Avianca la aerolínea más
grande de Colombia según viva Air la
fusión es la única salida ya que tiene
problemas financieros desde la pandemia
agravados por el aumento del precio del
combustible en 2022 y la depreciación
del peso colombiano Los sindicatos
alzaron su voz de protesta por los
trabajadores afectados
Ahí estamos protestando porque anoche
viva ya cerró toda la operación todos
estos trabajadores están en vilo y no
sabemos si van a continuar trabajando No
si viva no sobrevive todos ellos van a
quedar en la calle la aeronáutica
anunció que las compañías aéreas habían
casana y latam llevaran a los pasajeros
sin costo adicional a sus destinos
Aunque dependen de la disponibilidad de
sillas también otras aerolíneas de bajo
coste como Volaris wingo y viva aerobus
apoyará con precios especiales a Los
viajeros que iban con destino a Ciudad
de México y Cancún